que ce rsa revisité par le candidat
macro et les réactions que cette idée
provoque avec fabien rey caire
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans son
programme présidentiel s'il est réélu
emmanuel macron veut conditionner le rsa
à l'exercice d'une activité
il y aura dans cette réforme
l'obligation de consacrer 15 à 20 heures
par semaine pour une activité permettant
d'aller vers l'insertion professionnelle
cette formation en insertion soit
d'emploi et d'être mieux accompagnée de
dire y'a pas simplement une prestation
mais aussi un accompagnement abandonné
le caractère sans contrepartie du rsa
une mesure critiquée par l'ensemble des
acteurs de la lutte contre la pauvreté
alors l'entourage du chef de l'état
tente de rassurer et insiste sur
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires par
la formation les personnes avec des
problèmes de santé ou des obligations de
garde d'enfants ne seront pas concernées
a précisé depuis la ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes la droite quant à elle
reproche à emmanuel macron de copier une
mesure déjà présente dans le programme
de valérie pécresse la candidate et
l'air veut-elle aussi exiger des
contreparties au versement du rsa dans
la nouvelle france celui qui touche le
rsa donnera chaque semaine
15 heures d'activités à la société
15 heures hebdomadaires de travail
d'intérêt général
une mesure pour laquelle la candidate
n'apporte aucune précision concrètes de
mise en oeuvre à l'extrême droite on
veut aller encore plus loin eric zemmour
promet de supprimer les aides aux
étrangers extra-européens même en
situation régulière il faut enlever la
solidarité nationale aux étrangers c'est
à dire qu'il faut enlever le rsa les
allocations logement et les allocations
familiales
hier comment y compris pour les
personnes y compris les personnages
absolument si le durcissement de l'accès
au rsa s'est imposé à droite dans la
campagne à gauche pas question d'y
toucher anne hidalgo et yannick jadot
veulent même l'étendre aux 18 25 ans
quant à jean luc mélenchon il propose
une garantie d'autonomie 2063 euros nets
par mois pour tous
quarante minutes de débat tout de suite
c'est notre promesse tous les soirs dans
ce sens public un thème de la campagne
ou une proposition d'un candidat ou
d'une candidate et on en débat avec des
invités politiques kottmann un troublant
soir où cela vous êtes porte parole de
valérie pécresse vice-président de la
région ile-de-france rémy cardon bon
soir sénateur ps de la somme j'accueille
également pablo pino vivien responsable
éditorial de la revue regardant soir
l'agglo merci d'être là et puis avec
nous en duplex erwan balanant qui est
député modem du finistère bonsoir merci
à vous aussi quelques chiffres que je
rappelle le rsa ça concerne plus de deux
millions de foyers en france ses 575
euros pour une personne seule ce sera le
montant à partir du 1er avril et 863
euros pour un point couple othman nasro
comment vous avez réagi en entendant
emmanuel macron faire cette proposition
conditionnée à une quinzaine d'heures 15
20 heures d'activité écoutez je suis
surpris par le manque d'imagination des
manuels macron parce qu'il reprend la
affectivement une proposition de valérie
pécresse mais en même temps il ne la
reprends mal et ses propres de la
contrefaçon c'est que l es de mauvaise
qualité puisque en réalité on découvre
qu'il ya des grandes différences et
notamment qu' il la contrepartie qu'il
propose n'est pas forcément une
contrepartie obligatoire et donc en
réalité au moment même où il il fait
cette annonce il la vit tout de suite de
son sens et je crois que là c'est une
marque de fabrique du maquereau nîmes ce
fameux en même temps où on fait une
chose et fait son contraire à la fois ce
qui veut dire qu'on ne fait rien du tout
nous nous sommes attachés effectivement
cette contrepartie à la fois pour des
raisons de l'insertion mais aussi pour
des raisons de dignité aussi de des
allocataires du rsa et donc 15 heures
par semaine d'intérêt général au service
de la collectivité et bien sûr à
l'exception de ceux qui ne pourront pas
le faire pour des raisons par exemple de
santé et donc c'est une chose qui est un
engagement qui est très claire de la
part de valérie bègue récession il peut
y avoir des exceptions mais par contre
se sont hissés bien un travail d'intérêt
général et c'est bien obligatoire
autrement la location peut être suspendu
s'il n'ya pas encore une fois une vraie
raison de ne pas de ne pas échapper à
cette obligation ce qui n'est pas le cas
chez emmanuel macron je n'ai pas très
bien compris alors sur la base du
volontariat comme il l'a dit au début
avant que certains ministres viennent
dire des choses un peu contradictoire a
demandé tout de suite à la non silence
il a plus de détails aujourd'hui c'est
plusieurs jours après l annonce d
emmanuel macron
est ce que c'est un mauvais
copier/coller finalement de la
proposition de valérie pécresse
maintenant je crois que votre invité il
a il a assez bien résumé qu'on n'est pas
du tout dans le même type de dispositif
lui parle d'intérêt général et j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure valérie pécresse
dans l'extrait de que vous avez cités
que que le la locataire devrait quelque
chose en retour à la société c'est pas
du tout le dispositif que nous que nous
proposons le dispositif que nous
proposons c'est de le soumettre à de
l'accompagnement et l'accompagnement moi
j'ai été président d'une association
d'insertion pendant dix ans et je peux
vous le dire que si vous ne compreniez
pas les personnes qui sont au rsa il
n'arrive pas à s'en sortir et est
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est d'accompagner
par de l'insertion parfois par un
parcours qui peuvent qui peut être un
parcours social parcours d'une formation
parcours pourquoi pas d'une activité
mais le président l'a bien dit à partir
du moment où c'est une activité
rémunérée une activité professionnelle
elle sera au niveau du smic minimum et
elle viendra en complément de du rsa
vous pouvez pas aujourd'hui dans un dans
un moment où on est en train d'aller on
l'espère vers le plein emploi
il faut aller chercher les gens qui sont
loin du travail pour eux parce que
souvent ils ont envie de travailler ils
ont envie de participer à la société il
faut les accompagner et tous les
exemples de d'insertion qui fonctionne
passe par cet accompagnement prenons
l'exemple par exemple du territoire zéro
chômeur territoire zéro chômeur que qui
est qui avait été mise en place par les
socialistes et que nous avons comment
dire permis de nous avons permis que les
expérimentations continue et
s'élargissent c'est aussi la même chose
c'est de l'accompagnement et c'est comme
ça qu'on s'en sort c'est comme ça que
les personnes éloignées de l'emploi
censeurs vous aurez tous la parole
évidemment de rang dans ce débat merci
de pas faire des réponses non plus trop
longue
rémi gardon
l'insertion l'accompagnement de ceux qui
sont finalement éloigné de l'emploi
voilà le l'argument donné par erwan
balanant qu'est ce que vous proposez et
puis aussi quel est votre regard sur
cette stratégie on peut employer ce
terme là aussi des manuels mâcon alors
déjà juste expliqué à la majorité que
les départements font déjà un travail
considérable sur l'accompagnement des
personnes en public de plus tôt rsa
de sortir de ce genre de proposition
aujourd'hui ça démontre aussi la
déconnexion avec les territoires avec
les politiques sociales qui sont mis en
place par les départements encore
d'ailleurs vous regarderez dans vos
départements où la majorité ait l'air
vous avez d'ailleurs du mal à le alors
en obligatoire et aussi à la halle à
l'installer sur la partie accompagnement
notamment dans l'aisne j'ai un exemple
dans l'aisne où le département de
l'aisne a voulu imposer
15h20 heure
obligatoire aux bénéficiaires de rsa et
ils n'ont jamais fait pourquoi parce que
ça coûtait trop cher en accompagnement
et en charge et de 1066 messi mais vous
y passez que les départements n'ont pas
la plaine compétent mais vous verrez que
c'est un moyen parce que commencer c'est
un volet décentralisation des centres
dans le haut rhin où le bas-rhin je sais
plus quel départ de mais il me semble
que ce département la a fait une
tentative sur ce sujet sauf erreur de ma
part et je crois que ce département est
clair aujourd'hui en plus ok je vous le
redis aujourd'hui
en fait qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
accompagnement aussi dès aujourd'hui à
ckoi et qu'est ce qu'on met derrière cdc
décharger les fictions coup pourquoi
vous dites qui est un sujet de coût
quand on demande 15 heures de
contrepartie d'activité doit laisser
aller devant être des gens décident les
fonctionnaires qui vont faire ce
contrôle qui ne sert strictement à rien
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà des
dispositifs qui sont mis en place ça
soit avec pôle emploi ou avec le
département donc je troll de selectv
l'egypte comprend pas être organisées
par les communes et par les départements
qui ont des activités d'intérêt général
a proposé oui donc ya pas forcément des
fonctionnaires en plus qui viennent
contrôler est bien sûr que si vous le
savez très bien
locale et le problème c'est que vous
allez avoir du mal à trouver 2 millions
de projets comme ça du jour au lendemain
à poura pour pour pour chacun des
bénéficiaires du rsa aujourd'hui puisque
c'est le chiffre que vous avez donné
tout à l'heure c'est deux millions de
personnes qui touchent aujourd'hui le
rsa c'est très compliqué de le faire
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est que si
vous prenez entre 2014 et 2018 vous avez
une augmentation des revenus qui sont
octroyés au seo au rsa 2 25% et les
revenu d'insertion eux ils ont augmenté
que de 6 % donc effectivement moi
j'entends enfin à ce que ce que vous
dites sur l'accompagnement la nécessité
de l'insertion et c'est la question en
fait c'est plus une question rhétorique
c'est pourquoi est-ce que emmanuel
macron dans un discours programmatique
est allé mettre en parallèle en fait en
fait les gens qui sont les plus pauvres
de la société parce que vous publiez
vous avez donné tout à l'heure les
chiffres ça reste en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté donc on parle de gens qui sont
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté là vous
vous dites quoi il les montre du doigt
deux mais bien sûr qu'il les montre du
doigt bien sûr il est en train de dire
il en train de poser les travailleurs et
d en train de poser par dont les
françaises et les français entre eux est
en train de dire regardez d'un côté il
ya les assister il ya ceux qui profitent
du système et de l'autre côté en fait il
ya les bons travailleurs qui se lèvent
tôt le matin c'est ça qu'il a envie de
faire c'est ce que fait la droite depuis
depuis très longtemps et le pire c'est
que c'est en train de marcher moi j'ai
parlé avec des gens qui touchaient le
rsa là depuis que macron a fait cette
annonce c'est des gens qui me disent
mais en fait qui ont déjà du mal à
joindre les deux bouts qui sont eux qui
sont en survie dans fait dans la société
1 cd fall ce que dans l'est dans les
dents les gens qui touchent le rsa il ya
deux cent mille femmes seules avec
enfants et ses deux cent mille femmes
sol vous croyez que vous allez leur dire
bon maintenant vous allez vous mettre
leurs entreprises dans le dispositif d'
emmanuel macron puisque quand vous avez
des obligations de garde des enfants
vous n'êtes pas toujours très bien banal
et on donne la parole
erwan balanant là dessus parce que vous
venez d'entendre les arguments aussi de
pablo pino lien qui dit grosso modo 1 ce
sera quasiment impossible à mettre en
oeuvre parce qu'on trouvera jamais de
propositions pour deux millions de
personnes et puis 2 c voilà c'est une
stigmatisation des plus précaires ou des
plus pauvres des français que répondez
vous à ça alors bon déjà c'est justement
une volonté politique affirmée de la
part du président et du et du candidat
c'est de dire qu'il faut accompagner et
donc ça voudra dire effectivement qu'on
mettra plus de moyens tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé des départements oui ce
ne sont normalement les départements
khimki qui font le travail d'insertion
ce sens et leurs compétences mais
aujourd'hui on voit ce n'est pas
complètement fait donc il faudra il
faudra aller plus loin et sur la
stigmatisation c'est tout le contraire
c'est tout le contraire monsieur c'est
de dire qu'on ne peut pas laisser des
gens qui sont loin de l'emploi sans
solution on l'a fait pour un jeune une
solution ça a fonctionné on va le faire
exactement essais il faut le faire pour
justement des gens qui sont éloignés de
l'emploi qui sont au rsa qui ont des
difficultés qui sont parfois des
difficultés de logement des difficultés
sociales c'est tout ça qui fait qu'il
faut régler pour des allocataires pour
qu'il retrouve le chemin de l'emploi et
c'est ça que nous voulons faire eh oui
s'il faudra mais s'il faut mettre des
moyens supplémentaires nous le ferons
avec un élément est quelque chose je le
précise parce que c'est très important
on a d'un côté ses heures d'activités
d'accompagnement et de l'autre le le
versement automatique de ces personnes
viendra aujourd'hui c'est 700 millions
ce trimestre qui ne sont pas touchés on
y reviendra le versement automatique des
aides sociales à la source évidemment
c'est effectivement c'était l'une des
propositions de mâcon dont on a un peu
moins parler je la mets de sondage tient
pour éclairer ce débat pour essayer de
voir si cette mesure cette proposition
est populaire ou non c'est quasiment la
même question d'abord l'ifop pour le jdd
80 % des français sont pour une
contrepartie au rsa puis alors la
question de de l'institut csa c'est pour
ses news et là on à 68% des français
qu'ils pensent qu'il faut une
contrepartie d'activité au csa c'était
quand même douze points d'écart bond
notre débat et pas sur le la qualité des
sondeurs mais ça fait quand même un
écart c'est un peu quasiment la même
question mais je voudrais entendre ce
que ce que ça vous inspire rémi gardon
voilà cette mesure elle est aussi
populaire auprès d'une partie de
l'opinion une large partie qu'on soit 60
ou à 80% l'opinion français mais si on
pose la question justement aux
entreprises de câble du cac 40 qui ont
versé 60 9 milliards d'euros aux à leurs
actionnaires un record historique poser
la question si les efforts on les fait
si les actionnaires ont refait des
efforts aussi également entendre guy
parce que moi je pense que en cette
période de guerre vous répondez pas
exactement un mac et pc gifi je vous
réponds parce que vous pouvez aussi je
vous pose plutôt la question sur le fait
que aujourd'hui les efforts tout le
monde doit les faire beaucoup on vise
une seule partie la population pourquoi
emmanuel macron dans son programme
économique et social a visé deux
symboles de la république la retraite et
le rsa ont pourquoi à votre avis parce
qu'il est c'est à droite toute le cap et
et mener maintenant aujourd'hui les
choses sont claires de plus en plus
clair plus on avance dans le temps plus
les manama qu'on démontre que une
critique qui vaut d'ailleurs aussi pour
valence qui l'a reçu au fermement sur
une ligne on va pas alors je vais pas
dire similaires ça va vous arranger mais
sur la retraite ou sur le rsa qu'est ce
que vous répondez aux mots salue tous
marange simplement j'ai du mal à croire
qu emmanuel macron va faire demain à
linverse de ce qu'il a fait pendant cinq
ans sur ces sujets la prêtrise et malak
la critique de rémy car donc est ce que
vous y répondez bah écoutez je ne
comprends pas très bien la critique
parce que là c'est pas une mesure des
efforts ne sont
pas le sujet par sujet des forces sont
professeurs contrepartie c'est de
contrepartie la nommer vous parler des
bénéfices en hausse ont parlé des
bénéfices faisait pas interrompu vous
parliez des bénéfices des grands groupes
et là en l'occurrence je ne sais pas un
effort c'est une question d'insertion
c'est une question de dignité mais là
encore une formation à les comprendre
jusqu'à profession d'emmanuel macro elle
limite n'est toujours pas clair pour moi
est ce que c'est un accompagnement ou
est ce que c'est une activité comme nous
le propose j'ai fixé un accompagnement
mais c'est un accompagnement il n'est
pas rémunéré j'entends qui serait
rémunéré au smic tout cela est peu clair
parce que c'est improvisé parce que tu
n'es marche purement électorales qui ne
débouchent sur rien mais je ne laisserai
pas dire qu'on stigmatise qui que ce
soit nous avons réglé le répéterai ce
qu'on n'a jamais parlé de gens qui ne
sont rien
on n'a jamais dit qu'il n'y avait qu'à
traverser la rue pour trouver un emploi
tout travail mérite salaire nous pensons
que tous revenus mérite aussi une
contrepartie à la société et ça n'est
pas honteux ça n'est pas infamant ça ne
stigmatise personne au contraire c'est
un sujet dignité et effectivement nous
avons des gens qui sont parfois très
éloignées du monde du travail le
redonner une activité d'intérêt général
c'est important et pardon de dire que on
peut trouver des activités dans le
social dans l'accompagnement des plus
vulnérables au service de la
collectivité à raison de 15 heures par
semaine avec les communes qui sont à la
manoeuvre je crois que ce serait
salutaire et que ça règlerait une bonne
fois pour toutes ce débat c'est une
proposition qui est clair mais qui
s'inscrit aussi dans un projet global et
n'aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
sur d'autres points pablo pino beau de
réaction ensuite on se penche l'exemple
allemand le problème en fait c'est là
c'est la logique en fait de la droite
qui au gouvernement ou qui représenté
ici par par le sous
estime que le
candidat qui fait ce type de proposition
en fait que je pense que le le problème
c'est que la défaillance qui a
aujourd'hui dans le dans le dans
l'accompagnement de ces personnes qui
sont élus et de l'emploi elle vient de
la collectivité or ce que fait manuel
mâcon c'est qui fait poser il fait peser
cette responsabilité sur les personnes
il dit si vous n'avez pas un emploi si
vous êtes au rsa c'est si vous êtes
éloignés de l'emploi c'est parce que
vous avez un problème et vous vous
devriez vous mettre un peu vous sortir
les mains des poches etc est allée est
allée est allé faire des formations et
c'est pas le problème encore une fois il
vient de la collectivité cl c'est les
départements et les communes c'est
l'état en général c'est nous tous
finalement qui n'avons pas réussi à
faire que ces personnes puissent avoir
accès à un travail c'est comme ça qu'il
faut raisonner c'est comme ça en tout
cas calé à gauche on raisonne
avec la droite et c'est pour ça que je
mets emmanuel macron dans le même sac
que vous les moyens à briller pourquoi
ça n'est pas de droite sur un an pour un
exemple précis qui va les y rapidement
c'est ce contrat d'engagement jeunes qui
le met en place qui est pour moi un rsa
jeunes une allocation sans contrepartie
de 500 euros à 500 mille jeunes qui va
être versée d'ailleurs pour la première
fois dans quelques jours à dix jours de
l'élection
dans ciels seulement écouter non sinon
c'est un accompagnement ce n'est pas une
contrepartie il faut pointer la mission
locale ça ne m'aiment pas vers un emploi
il n'y a pas un vrai parcours de
formation nous nous proposons que ce
soit uniquement quand on est en
formation dans un métier en tension
olemps droit survenu à l'est qu'à un
clivage qui établissent alger entre
l'assertion et l'assistanat jeu et
manière accrue du côté de la cité nature
à l'allmend comme promis avec cet
exemple étrangers laetitia
jaujou à leur
nom je suis un garçon poli alors on est
allé vers l'exemple allemand mis en
place dans les années 2000 c'est ça
exactement c'était sous le gouvernement
schröder entre 2003 et 2005 les fameuses
lois hartz art c'était le nom de pétards
art le directeur du personnel de
volkswagen et l'esprit c'est vrai
c'était à peu près similaire à celui de
la mesure d' emmanuel macron puisque
l'allemagne et souffrait d'un taux de
chômage élevé à peu près 10% elle était
le mauvais élève à l'époque de l'europe
on l'a oublié et le gouvernement s'était
lui aussi lancé dans une réforme des
allocations touchés par les chômeurs
alors les chômeurs la mesure était la
suivante les chômeurs en fin de droit
avait l'obligation de prendre entre 15
et 30 heures de travail hebdomadaire et
on appelait ses jobs des mini jobs ou d
aïn euros jobs un euro le job pourquoi
parce que c'était l'heure de travail qui
étaient rémunérés entre 1 euro et 2,5
euros c'était obligatoire pour pouvoir
continuer à toucher les indemnités
d'accord et les allocataires de la fed
entre 15 et 30 heures de ces mini jobs
parle par mois quel résultat très
nuancée par exemple vous en parliez tout
à l'heure des des travaux qui étaient un
peu créé justement parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas assez pour répondre
soudainement à cette arrivée sur le
marché du travail des chômeurs de longue
durée nice matin à effet une enquête et
il avait révélé qu on avait créé un job
qui consistait à faire des puzzles de
5000 pièces pour compter les pièces et
pour communiquer aux fabricants s'il
leur manquait voilà donc c'était
vraiment créé dur sur mesure pour
pouvoir donner du travail et puis ce qui
est plus intéressant c'est la cour des
comptes qui s'est penché sur le cas
allemand et qui sort une note en 2013
avec une conclusion très pessimiste elle
les réformes hartz ont remis un emploi
des personnes sur des contrats
temporaires ou à temps partiel ne leur
permettant pas de dépasser le seuil de
pauvreté la conclusion elle est assez
simple thomas finalement en allemagne
les chiffres du chômage ont baissé mais
les inégalités et la pauvreté ont
augmenté juste à noter que concernant
ces mini jobs et les temps partiels il
concerne 80 % mais femmes ils sont
pourvus à 80% par des femmes erwan
balanant je reviens vers vous est ce que
finalement le fait que le candidat
emmanuel macron facettes proposition
c'est pas aussi une façon d'admettre que
le président emmanuel macron on n'a pas
réussi ce qu'il ce qu'il ambitionnait en
matière de lutte contre la pauvreté de
réinsertion mais enfin non non je suis
pas justement mon chien chien en totale
opposition avec ce que j'entends sur le
plateau de vos invités de la droite de
l'est de l'échiquier aux politiques ou
de la gauche de l'échiquier politique et
je crois qu'il mélange un peu justement
tout on n'est pas d'un côté on parle
d'intérêt général on n'est pas sur la
question de l'intérêt général quand on
parle d'un allocataire on est sur son
intérêt r particulier à trouver une
solution pour être réinsérés pour
participer à la société et monsieur
monsieur pipi au billet un kit qui nous
dit que c'est que nous que nous
stigmatisons et que nous sommes dans
dans quelque chose de la f1 que c'est
tout le contraire nous sommes en train
de dire personne ne doit rester sans
solution et n'importe quel citoyen
français doit être accompagnée pour
retrouver sa dignité effectivement par
le travail et parfois ça passe par une
formation prenons l'exemple de de la
réussite que nous avons réussi ce que
nous avons réussi dans ce quinquennat
sur la sur la lutte contre le chômage et
bien c'est justement parce qu'on a
développé des offres de formation qu'on
a reformé l'apprentissage qu'on a
réformé la façon dont les pôles emploi
travail et que on a réussi à baisser le
chômage et il faut avoir la même
démarche sur la question des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi et des personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui au rsa voilà et et
on est vraiment sur une position
d'équilibré
il faut aller les chercher les uns
compagne et et les remettre au travail
et c'est des gens qui ont envie de
travailler moi j'ai été je voulais dit
tout à l'heure président d'une
association d'insertion n'y a personne
qui règle qui aime rester chez lui à
rien faire ça n'existe pas les gens une
fois qu'on les accompagne pour leur a
donné les clés ils ont envie de
travailler et généralement ils
retravaillent il y avait des arguments
aux français de maurice pardon vous
interrompre rémi garde on va écouter
votre candidate anne hidalgo c'était ce
matin sur france 2 justement à propos de
voilà deux des plus précaires de nos
concitoyens elle évoque la souffrance
sociale de nombreux français donc de
stigmatiser les plus fragiles les
pauvres il ferait mieux de prendre
conscience de la réalité sociale du pays
de cette souffrance sociale on n'a pas
besoin de stigmatisation on n'a pas
besoin d'opposer les français ceux qui
travaillent rennes ceux qui ne
travaillent pas et ça je crois que ces
deux droite et de droite opposition de
droite et de droite dit anne hidalgo à
propos de cette réforme du rsa a évoqué
par par emmanuel macron que propose
votre candidate pour les plus précaires
ben oui c'est très simple on avait une
idée assez phare sur ça a été dit tout à
l'heure le territoire zéro chômeur et
s'était lancé ça a été repris par
laurent grandguillaume qui a continué
avec la majorité présidentielle sauf que
nous là on va un peu plus loin ce
notamment sur la partie
emplois verts on est sûr aussi dans une
logique de d'utiliser un dispositif
existant le territoire zéro chômeur dans
les territoires pour l'amplifier a une
dimension et en prenant partie justement
sur la transition écologique donc c'est
cdu des terribles investisseurs vous
pouvez nous le rappeler en fait il ya
quand même une contrepartie aux six
essais ce prince ça c'est de lutter
contre le chômage de longue durée donc
c'est ça touche essentiellement des
personnes donc c'est les deux les
obliger à certaines heures pour à la
collectivité cesser
sur les notions bien sûr donc qu'est-ce
qui bloque alors avec la mesure d'
emmanuel macron mais en fait la mesure
de mes vacances c'est juste un symbole
pour attirer des électeurs de droite
c'est juste ça la mesure de manuel
maquereau en fait en réalité et des
choses qui existent déjà les
départements font des choses dans les
territoires c'est pour ça moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un débat où on fait
un débat de la prière de la droite en
fait voilà non mais d'abord encore une
fois emmanuel macron voyez qu'il a
rétropédalé sitôt qu'il en a fait
l'annoncé tout de suite ce n'est plus
une contrepartie c'est une formation
j'entends l instant donc on voit tout de
suite qu'il ya un malaise au sein de la
majorité parce qu'il n'est pas clair sur
ce sujet mais pardon moi je constate
qu'effectivement prend vous faites ce de
cette expérimentation des territoires
zéro chômeur qu'on sait les socialistes
qui le font il n'y a pas de problème et
quand c'est valérie pécresse qui propose
on parle de stigmatisation ça ça n'est
pas possible bon est ce que est ce que
ce système fonctionne aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il faut le réformer ce chiffre la
source et l'adresse 34 % des foyers
éligibles ça représente quand même 600
mille ménages qui ont droit au rsa se
retrouve finalement exclu parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle le taux de non
recours au rsa est effectivement dans
les propositions évoquées par par le
candidat macro il ya cette idée d'un
versement automatique des aides sociales
à la source erwan balanant ça pourrait
marcher comment çà
çà çà çà va être ça va être mis en place
c'est on a réussi à faire l'impôt à la
source tout le monde nous disait que ça
serait pas possible on réussira à faire
cette prestation sociale à la source de
la même façon j'ai pas exactement
comment techniquement ça va fonctionner
meurt en tout cas l'idée elle est là
c'est que chaque personne dans notre
pays qui a le droit à des aides sociales
les touchera et ça c'est important et ça
ça jeu j'attends vos vos deux invités de
gauche me dire que c'est une mesure de
droite je l'attends avec impatience y
ont justement c'est clair mais je vais
beaucoup parlé j'essaie d'équilibrer le
temps de parole ces tableaux qui vient
là dessus mais c'est pas souvent vous
avez raison c'est pas forcément une
mesure de droite mais moi je pense qu'en
fait il faut il faut il faut distinguer
deux choses en fait d'une part ya la
question de la solidarité c'est ça le
rsa le s2 de rsa c'est solidarité et
donc il faut absolument empêcher
quiconque de tomber dans la dans la
pauvreté voire dans l'extrême pauvreté
donc il faut avoir cessé ses revenus
minimaux peu importe les cas de figure
on doit pouvoir dit traitement et donc
le versement automatique des aides
sociales souhaite une bonne et
exactement c'est une très bonne idée et
il faut renforcer le rsa il faut le
passer au dessus bien sûr du niveau de
pauvreté c'est inadmissible qu'ils
soient aujourd'hui en dessous du du
dumont du seuil de pauvreté et dans un
autre temps il ya la question de
l'accompagnement et de et de l'insertion
dans le monsieur le député modem a parlé
tout à l'heure mais en fait il faut
décorrélé de corréler les deux c'est là
que c'est là que je vous dit vous êtes
de droite si vous corréler les deux la
solidarité n'a rien à voir avec
l'obligation d'aller travailler ou
l'obligation de faire des formations etc
parce que c'est une carte parce que qui
dit il lui qui dit kankankan macron fait
c'est quand même agnel macron fait
c'était en fait sur la caisse qui fait
foi il dit si jamais vous ne faites pas
c'est 15 à 20 heures je vais vous
retirez le rsa vous ne serez plus
éligibles au rsa et c'est là que ça
devient dramatique on peut pas laisser
des gens même s'ils ne veulent pas faire
sécher dans inventa les audois allaient
laisser tomber dans l'extrême pauvreté à
one bâle en europe est très très très
éloignée de la réalité du travail
d'insertion vraiment moi je peux vous
dire tout tout ce qui fonctionne sur le
travail d'insertion c'est quand on
accompagne les gens et quand on laisse
les gens sans solutions on les perd et
c'est là monsieur je vous déjà crise et
la compagnie dans la danse en beauté et
et moi j'ai rencontré des gens qui
n'avaient même qu'ils ne savaient même
pas qu'ils pouvaient toucher le rsa et
le fait qu'ils touchent le rsa c'était
le début de la bouée de sauvetage qui
permettait de mettre en place un
parcours et c'est ça qu'il faut faire et
c'est ça que nous allons faire avec
cette automaticité qui va permettre à
des gens de ne pas sombrer et cet
accompagnement qui va permettre à ces
gens de décoller othman va se trouver je
crois une question pour erwan balanant
oui très simple est ce qu'il y aura des
cas où le rsa sera suspendu si c'est un
accompagnement il ne peut pas être
suspendue vers la liste pécresse on est
très clair si sans motif valable il n'y
a pas ces 15 heures d'activités
d'intérêt général le rsa sera suspendu
est-ce que c'est également votre carte
c'est toute la différence entre votre
système où on doit quelque chose à la
société et notre système qui insiste m
humaniste qui fera en sorte de sortir
des gens d'une situation aurait karité
du volontariat et donc en fait l'annoncé
c'est exactement entre la différence
entre un programme progressiste et
humaniste et un programme de droite et
conservateurs comme le vote donc vous
nous confirmer qu'il n'y a pas de
contrepartie contrairement à ce
qu'indique emmanuel macron lors de sa
conférence de presse c'est les
contreparties elles sont c'est ce qui
est marqué dans le programme c'est un
accompagnement on ne l'est il va les
housses andré si jamais le rsa à
personne
ce que voulait dire comment bah moi
personnellement je ne pense pas qu'il
faut le suspendre et tout à fait mais
moi je ne suis pas le président qui
laissera la comme toute mesure est la
lll et mes condoléances député matte
ronis voulait y en a certains de ce que
présente la république il ya peu de
chances qu'ils le mettent en oeuvre sera
peut-être d'état par le candidat
je propose à nico qui de nous deux nous
rejoindre pour évoquer comment le le
sénat bonsoir à fanny bienvenue a déjà
travaillé sur sur ce sujet évidemment il
en a souvent été question ici est
notamment avoir effectivement le rsa un
sujet dont il est souvent question à
droite thomas est un des axes majeurs on
l'a vu c'est le retour à l'emploi faire
en sorte que les allocataires soit actif
mettre en place un retour durable dans
l'activité et au sénat effectivement il
ya une propice de proposition de loi qui
a été déposé et adopté l'année dernière
un texte de claude malhuret sénateur de
l'allier qui fait partie des macros nist
c'est le président du groupe les
indépendants des prêts publics et
territoires en avril 2021 donc l'année
dernière les sénateurs avaient en effet
adopté cette proposition loi dont
l'objectif était de favoriser le retour
à l'emploi pour les bénéficiaires du rsa
le texte permettait aux allocataires de
cumuler les revenus d'une activité
salariée et le revenu de solidarité
active pour une durée d'un an qui
ensuite a été porté à neuf mois donc je
vous propose d'écouter claude malhuret à
ce sujet il explique la tonalité de ce
texte c'était donc en séance l'année
dernière au sénat et coûter actuellement
une personne sans emploi qui arrivent en
fin de droit et perd son allocation
chômage perçoit le rsa elle perçoit
aussi des apl est un ensemble de droits
connexes tels que la cmu c
accès à des tarifs sociaux pour
l'électricité la cantine scolaire les
transports etc lorsque cette même
personne retrouve un travail elle va
très rapidement perdre la totalité du
rsa et l'ensemble de ses droits ou en
tout cas une bonne partie au profit de
son nouveau salaire et de la prime
d'activité soit 200 euros par mois en
moyenne
la perte des minima sociaux et des
droits connexes mais compensés qu'en
partie en particulier pour les contrats
à temps partiel par la prime d'activité
on enlève pas une béquille à une
personne longtemps immobilisé qui vient
tout juste de se remettre à marcher
mieux vaut lui laisser la possibilité de
s'en servir jusqu'à ce que sa démarche
plus assuré lui permettre de se mouvoir
librement chance est
alors sur la base d'une initiative du
département de l'allier le texte
prévoyait une expérimentation locale
pour une durée de quatre ans dans les
départements volontaires avec par
exemple une insertion dans les tpe les
pme locales ensuite pour évaluer s'il
fallait généraliser le dispositif s'il
était efficace une évaluation était
prévu sur la base de rapports établis
par les départements justement et par le
gouvernement mais si le texte a donc
effectivement été adopté au sénat contre
l'avis du gouvernement cette proposition
de loi n'a finalement jamais vu le jour
en effet jusqu'à maintenant le texte n'a
jamais été mis à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale le texte n'a donc
pas été débattue par les députés et
cette fois n'a donc jamais été promulgué
merci fanny
histoire parlementaire finalement
intéressantes à raconter on est dans une
autre proposition rémi caron cumuler les
revenus d'une activité salariée avec le
revenu de solidarité active pour
faciliter finalement le retour à
l'emploi qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'aime bien la formule finalement de
claude malhuret quand il dit on enlève
pas une bille qui a une personne
longtemps immobilisé qui vient tout
juste de se remettre à marcher ça existe
sur des incubateurs d'entreprises oui je
crois qu'il ya des dispositifs en tout
cas dans ma région c'est le cas il ya
des centres d association qui s'appelle
la bg e qui accompagne les entrepreneurs
à créer leur entreprise et donc ils sont
acculés ils donc ils ont tous le
bénéfice qu'ils font de leur entreprise
et leur verse dans l'incubateur et ils
détiennent toujours leurs droits sociaux
le avec le rsa donc ça existe sur sa sur
des cas particuliers c'est comme ça
donc l'idée vous la trouvez plus tôt
c'est à dire c'est juste la moindre des
choses mais encore faut-il peut être
revalorisé aussi le le rsa et puis
peut-être l'ouvrir
il ya aussi des on n'aurait pas parlé il
ya des catégories d'âge qui est sont
exclus du revenu solidarité est-ce que
effectivement en contrepartie de la
mesure que propose valérie pécresse
c'est à dire vraiment de conditionner le
rsa à cette activité et donc ça veut
dire que si un refus d'activité on ne
verse plus rsa est ce que vous proposez
d'augmenter le rsa par
d'abord j'aimerais rappeler qu'on veut
on est en train de revenir en réalité
que valérie pécresse à la philosophie
même du rsa parce que si effectivement
le s voulait dire solidarité le havre
les directives et al dès l'origine il y
avait un rsa socle et et ensuite une
partie qui pouvaient se cumuler avec un
revenu ce sont dix années de socialisme
c'est mon sentiment avec transcende et
avec emmanuel macron sur ce sujet qui
ont conduit à détricoter ce rsa en faire
un revenu qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui il n'est plus un revenu
d'insertion c'est ça qui est dommage et
donc en l'occurrence pour vous répondre
très clairement pour moi l'objectif
n'est pas de revaloriser le rsa c'est de
faire en sorte que ce soit ça soit
transitoire et que rapidement ce soit
l'emploi qui prennent le relais et donc
cette idée selon laquelle il faut que
les gens restent au rsa le plus
longtemps possible et qui n'est jamais
d'autres perspectives je ne me résous
pas et donc dans le projet de loi
pécresse vous avez aussi beaucoup
d'autres mesures et je ne crois pas du
tout que nous en soyons plein emploi
comme je l'aï entendu tout à l'heure au
contraire par rapport à la ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays européens nous
ne sommes pas si bon que ça sur les
chiffres de l'emploi et donc je crois
qu'il ya un gros travail à faire y
compris de libération des énergies
création d'emplois et une formation
professionnelle je ne crois pas que
renforcer des revenus d'assistance ce
soit la bonne solution parce que ça doit
être des revenus transitoire pablo pino
bien c'est vraiment de philosophie
différente oui c'est vraiment je suis
complètement complètement différente moi
j on va juste revenir une dernière fois
arrêté et pour tous les gens qui nous
écoutent les montées de lait gens qui
sont aussi autour de cette table en fait
vous mettre à la place de quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui reçoit reçoit le rsa donc
encore une fois comme vous l'avez rien
au contraire ment on cherche on cherche
les solutions
imaginées que la proposition d' emmanuel
macron en fait il s'adresse à des gens
qui sont déjà galèrent pour trouver un
logement
les billets déjà une peu importe aux
gestes de valérie pécresse c'est à dire
que on est sûr déjà sur des gens qui
galèrent pour avoir un logement qui
galèrent en fait pour trouver un emploi
parce qu'on leur propose des formations
mais en fait ces gens ils sont aussi
parfois dans la recherche d'un emploi
donc c'est à dire que pendant 15 à 20
heures on les empêche de chercher un
emploi on leur dit faites une formation
et la troisième chose c'est que c'est
des gens essayer de vivre avec moins de
moins de 600 euros par mois c'est c'est
une épreuve de toutes les heures de
toutes les minutes et ça nécessite
parfois en fait un engagement de la
personne qui parfois ces 24 heures sur
24 donc leur dire en plus de ça on va
vous rajoutez un truc par dessus parce
que vous vous êtes fautif parce que
c'est à cause de vous c'est parce que je
fasse est de votre faute si vous ne
travaillez pas aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être parce que vous dites vous mais
c'est ce qu'a dit i'm back rond quand il
parle de ceux qui ne sont rien et qu'il
faut traverser la rue pour avoir un job
je trouve ça absolument je veux dire je
dirai un mot grossier mais absolument
dégueulasse mais vous qui connaissez
bien les allocataires du rsa visiblement
et dites-nous mais vraiment c'est une
question très premier degré 1 et aucun
cynisme si par exemple on propose à une
personne qui a le rsa de d'avoir cette
activité qui permet effectivement à une
fille n'est pas ce que j'espère quand
même que le politique a dit viser plutôt
positive de l'insérer de la ré insérer
de la raccrocher à la société quel est
le problème en fait comment il n'y a
absolument aucun problème
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure si
vous la non mais si vous proposez s'il
ya une démarche mais sans parler en fait
de conditionner le rsa à cet
accompagnement à cette insertion il faut
complètement décorer les deux faces été
remises ce qui ne va pas c'est bien
aussi bien sûr c'est de là que vient la
stigmatisation sinon bien sûr qu'il faut
accompagner les gens pour les jeunes
pour les réinsérer refuserait d'être
qu'ils ont
exactement il ya des accidents de la vie
on a
redonné la parole à erwan balanant qui
kivu qui veulent apprendre et qui nous
fait signe
mais d'abord on va écouter vous l'avais
un peu évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
finalement si on essaie de se poser la
question de l'applicabilité louer pas
très joli de cette mesure écoutez ce
qu'en dit geoffroy roux de bézieux le
président du medef c'était sur notre
antenne ce lundi
difficulté c'est de trouver je crois
qu'il ya 500 g + chiffres exacts cinq
cent mille personnes qui sont
suffisamment de formation c'est ça pour
ces gens suffisamment de déboucher le
principe me paraît
philosophiquement en tout cas on tente
d'hab la difficulté c'est de trouver des
entreprises des formations ou des
associations pour les accueillir erwan
balanant est-ce que c'est réaliste
finalement cette mesure dure à peine 2
million cent mille personnes qui sont
bénéficiaires du rsa eh bien il faut
justement mettre les moyens pour que ça
devienne réaliste c'est tout l'enjeu est
tout à leur monsieur py au vieil indice
est on va les empêcher d'aller d'aller
trouver un emploi parce qu'on va leur
prendre deux doigts par par cette
activité ça va les empêcher mais non
mais ça peut justement être sale
activités l'activité ça peut être d'être
apprendre d'apprendre à rédiger un cv à
retravailler à faire un parcours de 1 un
parcours de compétences internes aulas
monsieur existe déjà mais non elle
s'active déjà tout à fait ça existe déjà
dans tant de cinq ans est allé voir la
position de
[Musique]
pôle emploi il était un instant dans ma
circonscription
avec thé avec des acteurs de l'emploi
donc ça tombe très mal je connais ce
sujet assez bien donc c'est justement
effectivement ce qui se passe mais pas
pour tout le monde et il ya des gens
qu'il faut accompagner plus qui me
qu'elles ne sont aujourd'hui c'est tout
et c'est pas du tout une volonté de
stigmatiser c'est une volonté de très
efficace et d'arriver à un résultat
parce que moi personnellement je ne
tolère pas une société et là je pense
que je rejoins tout le monde sur ce
plateau enfin j'espère une société où
des gens sont désinsérer où des gens
sont exclues de la société c'est tout et
c'est ça qu'il faut aller faire il faut
aller chercher au cas par cas
la parole à laetitia cru rémi garde ont
juste une question les allocataires du
rsa sont déjà suivis par des employés de
pôle emploi dans ce chemin de la
réinsertion est ce que vous nous dites
non mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que ce qui est dit par monsieur là
c'est de faire un cv outre il existe
déjà des ateliers et des structures qui
font aimer est ce que chaque allocataire
du rsa est suivi ou pas
non666 on a vu la majeure partie comme
ils peuvent on peut pointer à pôle
emploi éloignés de l'emploi depuis très
longtemps mais c'est pas ça pour le coup
ce n'est pas une obligation mais ça
c'est le travail justement de la
collectivité de la puissance publique en
général en fait d'aller en fait vers ces
gens qui sont comme inc comme le
monsieur l'a dit exclue éloignez éloigné
de tout est allé les chercher le mets
moi j'entends tout à fait ça il faut le
faire mais je vois pas le rapport avec
le rsa autre menace rouge je vous
propose de réagir aussi à ce que disait
geoffroy roux de bézieux parce que
finalement vous êtes sûr sur une
peut-être presque encore un peu plus dur
on l'a compris que celle de d'emmanuel
macron mai mais quelle formation qu'elle
quel processus d'accompagnement il faut
les trouver quoi les deux millions de
stages ou de formation alors encore une
fois nous ne sommes pas sur des
formations des stages et vous avez
raison de dire que c'est différent de la
proposition d' emmanuel macron dont on
voit qu'en réalité elle n'était qu'une
annonce nous c'est de l' activité
d'intérêt général nous avons dans notre
vie dans notre pays des communes des
départements qui cherche des volontaires
sur un tout un tas d'activités au
service de la collectivité et annoncé le
lancement très clair gc ca y est les
critères du jury au détriment de
l'emploi parce que normalement c'est
c'est havre travaux d'intérêt général il
pourrait y pourrait être être
non je l'assuré par des gens qui
cherchent cherchent un emploi je ne
crois pas cette idée que le travail se
partagent comme c'est un débat noble
beaucoup de gens à gauche le pensent et
en l'occurrence en parle pas tout à fait
d'activités qui aurait été rémunéré
autrement je parlais le service de la
collectivité on peut imaginer
effectivement de l'aide aux personnes
vulnérables
un travail de nature associative met au
service de la collectivité mais ce que
je veux ce que je précisais simplement
que ce soit bien clair si évidemment l
allocataire du rsa on le lui proposait
nous proposons aussi d'augmenter le
nombre de services civils mais en
l'occurrence yann l mais ça concerne que
les jeunes le service civique ça ne
concerne que les jeunes mais un look
ancien allocataires du rsa ne se voient
pas proposer une activité de ce type là
bien sûr qu'il gardera son allocation à
ces options n'est pas en capacité d'en
fournir suffisamment et bien évidemment
qu'on ne pénalisera personnes et nous ne
proposerons pas des émissions qui sont à
l'autre bout du département pas tout ça
doit être fait intelligemment mais il ya
un principe qui est posée par valérie
pécresse qui est si on touche sur
bénéfices et la solidarité nationale il
faut qu'il y ait une contrepartie au
service de la collectivité c'est ça le
principe si beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat et j'espère que ça
vous a aidé téléspectateurs à faire
votre choix et à mieux comprendre ce que
proposent les uns et les autres sur la
question de la précarité de la lutte
contre la précarité et du retour à
l'emploi pour ceux qui en sont éloignés
depuis trop longtemps